[Música]
[Aplausos]
a noite escura e negra
a brilhar
tiê estrela
ela
a pagar luz laranja do pó blush quero
dançar sobrando no
[Risadas]
i e ii escura e negra
[Música]
brilham de estrela
o bug a boo sua franja do pobre chiquero
dançada sob a luz da lua
[Música]
explorar negra brilhante estrela vai à
luz laranja no poste quero o ganso
dentro de si no ar
[Música]
i furar liga árabe anjos de estrela
a apae há luz nem jogo foge quero do
sucesso cantando
[Música]
existe uma lenda na colômbia que fala
sobre francisco oscot
ele era um músico viajante que viajava
pela colômbia para contar as notícias de
uma qualidade pra outra
mas ele é muito mais conhecido como
homem que venceu o diabo com uma sanfona
nós da insurgência surgimos como um
espetáculo teatral com musical mas
conforme cué o tempo que nós iríamos
apresentando as pessoas que nos assistiu
nos nomearam como banda e com a voz do
povo é a voz de deus nós acatamos
mas a gente nos considera banda não há e
se considera um bando quando as pessoas
que nos assistem cantam conosco elas
fazem parte desse bando e hoje eu
convido vocês a fazê lo sair como
francisco a vencermos os nossos medos as
nossas batalhas
através desses versos aqui noite escura
negra
a lu marinha de estrelas
a avaya luz laranja no bosque quero essa
subida no joá
a noite escura liga lua brilhante
estrela pagar luz laranja de bosch quero
lançar sob a luz do luar rua
[Música]
[Aplausos]
obrigado
[Música]
joão pessoa delineava todas as suas
histórias
toda sua memória daquele estado caótico
ocasionalmente imprevisível tempestuoso
o primitivo o selvagem chorará pelas
águas ricas daquele rio que já não
existe mais
seu coração se transformou no mar de
lágrimas de saudade
aqueles olhos de quem queria ser por
inteiro sem se deixar levar por todos os
julgamentos modelos a procura estar vivo
de tirar de si todo aquele o fôlego toda
aquela vida prometida na tv
o cônsul consumo que hoje modela quem
somos nada tinha a ver com aquilo a
necessidade
a tristeza saudade do rio que já não
existe mais e assim como rio
o exuberante profundo atrair para si
toda a origem
ah
[Música]
tem muito essa estrada pi por cá
com luiza indigesto em tricot
a data pode como uri isso corre pico
enjoada morte sangue na boca
aqui em peru já dobra semasa olheiras e
esses negros de aço rugas de sabedoria a
culpa o frasco do cansaço mas de que
vale saber se é na pura brisa vitral que
a anomia
mas de que vários abc na pureza pitéu
que alumia mas de que vale o saber se é
na pura pureza vida é o calo me ia mas
de que vale saber
nidinho mpe cruzamentos 11 balas de
vento estrelas soltas sinais fechados
segue cia emboscada
você só mais um instante s sony bonita
dança madrugada
use só mais um instante s sony bonita
dança madrugada por si só mais um
instante esse sonho infinita nessa
madrugada por si só mais um instante
assim sonho infinita dessa madrugada
[Música]
o teto
obrigado criando como a gente disse a
gente nós somos membros da banda
insurgência sertaneja essa é uma das
canções que a gente faz com a banda e
tem no spotify youtube ouvi lá que vai
estar não só nós dois mas tem a voz a
melhor da gg uma baiano paraense nós
somos do interior de são paulo cada um
de um lugar
então é uma mistura lá né as pessoas nos
perguntam nosso mais gente o sertanejo
já remexe ao sertanejo universitário e
na verdade a nossa é outro sertanejo né
a gente toca na verdade vários ritmos
que como já foi dito é a nossa
influência são as manifestações
populares é dos sertões brasileiros
então tem carimbó aqui da região de
minas a congada que é um ritmo
tradicional é uma moda de viola né de
minas então tem muita coisa ou rural
rock rural tem muita coisa misturada ao
a insurgência porque é o bonito do mundo
é isso a diversidade não é fazer uma
resumo a quinta
bem antes aqui de fora eu quero ver de
pé descalço na grama molhada você
acordando sobre amanhecer
[Música]
bem antes aqui de fora eu quero vir de
pé descalço na grama molhada você
acordando sob amanheci as cordas no meu
violão esticão em busca do fio do
paranal não deixe de ver nossa horta até
que a gente não está tão mal bem antiga
que de fora eu quero vir de pet
descalços na grama molhada você
acordando sobre amanhecer bem antiga que
de fora eu quero ver de ter descalços na
grama molhada você acordando sobre
amanhecer
o café da manhã em 6 improvisada de
madeira usada lá no pé de romã chamando
a gente pelo cheiro
nosso foco ontem mandou nem o dia
inteiro vem é que de fora eu quero vir
de pet descalços na grama molhada você
acordando subir amanhecer
[Música]
quem antes aqui de fora eu quero 20 pet
descalços na grama molhada é você
acordando sob amanheci se vier o medo da
mudança
o semae seu e um arreda o pé e se o
silêncio quiser parar a nossa dança aço
via cansan
amigos
[Música]
andré
obrigado muito obrigado
[Música]
[Aplausos]
eu sou do sertão num e você me eu sou do
sertão e você lê ou não eu sou do sertão
e você meu irmão eu sei meu irmão eu sou
do sertão e do seu irmão e você meu
irmão defendeu não ia ser nem mal e
vencemos por semana
[Música]
obrigado a treinar esta tarde lê e
pedras que delícia né acho que todo
mundo aqui gosta de café né
com certeza quem não gosta muito difícil
ea gente não conhece o efeito do café
a gente está tranqüilo às vezes estava
tomando café ou porque vai fazendo
efeito vai chegando o efeito café
exigindo mais inspirado nisso a gente
pensa canção
[Música]
o
bom
[Música]
[Aplausos]
é
[Música]
o câmbio
muito obrigado a rosas foi resolvido
o brasil está aqui hoje se encontra por
agora na internet os meditai por essas
estradas da vida muito obrigada muito
obrigada até de muito obrigado é ver
link nos deus o contato um excelente fim
de ano a todos e espero que a música
sempre ilumine o caminho de todos muito
obrigada